uns wertes der vergangenen tage das
wollen wir noch mal erläutern
aber das dienstag der 12 2020 mit
professor lars schaade vizepräsident des
robert koch instituts wie immer gibt es
erste statement und danach sind fragen
der medienvertreter die angemeldet sind
möglich guten morgen meine damen und
herren ich möchte zunächst wie auch in
der vergangenheit üblich einen kurzen
überblick über die epidemiologische
situation kurz in der welt und auch in
deutschland geben wo wir euch dann zum
eigentlichen thema die produktionszahl
komme weltweit gesehen gibt es sind es
weiterhin die staaten die sie bereits
kennen aus der vergangenheit die die
meisten fälle haben
das sind die vereinigten staaten spanien
das vereinigte königreich italien die
russische föderation und auch
deutschland die vereinigten staaten mit
1,32 millionen fällen 79.000 500
todesfällen einem anteil der
verstorbenen unter den gemeldeten fällen
von sechs prozent spanien 224.000 400
fällen 26.600 todesfällen
das ist ein anteil der verstorbenen von
11,9 prozent
das war eigentlich die königreich mit
219 1235 1900 todesfällen einem anteil
der verstorbenen von 14 5 prozent
italien mit 219.000 100 fällen 30.600
todesfällen dass es ein hunter der
verstorbenen von 13 9 prozent die
russische föderation mit 209 1700 fällen
1900 gemeldeten todesfällen dass es
einen anteil von 0,9 prozent
mittlerweile sind mehr als vier
millionen fälle weltweit bekannt und
gemeldet worden
nahezu alle länder berichten fälle und
besonders aktiv ist das
ausbruchsgeschehen im moment in
nordamerika brasilien und europa in
deutschland wurden bis heute 0 uhr
insgesamt 170 1508 cupid 19 fälle an das
robert koch institut übermittelt
in der letzten woche
wurden circa 700 bis 1300 fälle pro tag
übermittelt am letzten wochenende war es
war es weniger fälle gestern wieder
circa 1000 fälle genau 933 fälle
die zahlen bleiben also in etwa
vergleichbar mit den zahlen der letzten
woche die zahl der genesenen schätzen
wir auf 147 1200 bis heute wurden 700
7533 todesfälle an uns übermittelt in
der letzten woche wurden ca 100 bis 200
neue todesfälle pro tag übermittelt am
wochenende waren es dann 20 bis 30 neue
todesfälle und aktuell sind es wieder
116 gemeldeten todesfälle
gestern dann gemeldet bis heute null uhr
der anteil der verstorbenen ist in den
letzten wochen kontinuierlich gestiegen
auf aktuell 4,4 prozent die fallzahlen
und die zahl der genesenen werden
täglich aktualisierte sie können sie
detailliert auf unserem der sport
abrufen
es gibt jeden tag auch einen neuen
situationsbericht mit einer
lage-einschätzung den sie auf unserer
website finden und der täglich gegen
etwa 18 uhr aktualisiert sind wird das
sind die neuesten zahlen und nun möchte
ich noch ein paar worte zur aktuell
geschätzten reproduktions zahl eher
sagen er war ja schon also die
produktionszahl häufiger thema in diesem
briefing aber um die bedeutung noch mal
einordnen zu können
und auch die aktuelle erhöhung über ein
paar tage über 1 möchte ich noch einmal
die berechnung des erwerbes erklären und
wie wir den mehrwert aktuell einschätzen
seit samstag liegt der wert leicht über
1 und das ist der grund und der anlass
dass wir heute dieses pressebriefing
noch mal machen
so beginnen möchte ich aber betonen und
vorweg schicken dass die produktionszahl
nur ein parameter ist um die dynamik der
übertragung zu beurteilen
tagesaktuelle schwankungen sind möglich
aufgrund verzögerter meldungen von daten
deshalb sollten schwankungen um die zahl
eins der reproduktion zahl auch in der
gesamtlage bewertet werden
ein anderer wichtiger parameter zur
bewertung der dynamik ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen die ja auch im rahmen der
7 tages inzidenz pro 100.000 einwohner
auf landkreisebene in unserem dashboard
angegeben wird
insbesondere sind hier mögliche lokale
ausbruchsherde zu betrachten
darüber hinaus ist die zahl der
durchgeführten und davon positiv
ausgefallenen tests auch wichtig zur
beurteilung der gesamtsituation und für
die entscheidung ob und in welcher
stärke welcher art stärkere maßnahmen
ergriffen werden müssen sind ganz
wesentlich auch die aktuelle schwere der
erkrankung also todesfälle pro fallen
und intensivstation aufenthalte profile
und die b und auslastung des
gesundheitswesens zum beispiel engpässen
den gesundheitsämtern oder verfügbare er
intensiv und beatmungs betten nun
nochmal zum hintergrund des marketings
dass er die grundlage für die schätzung
der reproduktion stylist die meldedaten
zu den einzelnen fällen werden jeden tag
an das robert koch institut übermittelt
die neu ermittelten fälle sind auf den
sehr sportlich erwähnte er es bereits
und dem täglichen lagebericht als cupid
19 fälle pro tag nach melde datum
sichtbar das melde datum ist dabei der
tag an dem das gesundheitsamt die fälle
elektronisch erfasst hat teilweise
werden die fälle erst mit einem abstand
von vier bis zehn tagen dem rk ii
gemeldet
an den wochenenden und am montag
erhalten wir zudem regelmäßig weniger
neue fall meldungen was daran liegt dass
die menschen am wochenende weniger zum
arzt gehen nicht alle praxen geöffnet
sind und auch nicht alle
gesundheitsämter am wochenende
übermitteln
dieses melde datum das wird dann wird
bekommt bekommen liegt naturgemäß einige
tage nachdem erkrankungs dato das
erkrankung start um spiegelt aber den
verlauf der epidemie viel besser
bei etwas über zwei drittel der
meldungen die bei uns eingehen kennen
wir aus den fallbezogenen angaben das
erkrankungs datum genau und tragen es in
der epidemiologischen kurve kurve 19
fälle pro tag nach erkrankungsbeginn
ebenfalls im dashboard auf kennen wir
das erkrankungs datum nicht benutzen wir
in dieser darstellung ersatzweise das
melde datum nun ein möglichst
realistisches bild des epidemie verlauf
zu erhalten müssen wir die lücken die es
durch den genannten
übermittlungsversuche und die fehlenden
angaben des erkrankungsbeginn es gibt in
einem modell durch schätzung auffüllen
das ist der so genannte no casting dass
sie täglich im lagebericht sehen können
hierzu werden zuerst alle fälle von dem
wir das erkrankungs datum kennen nach
diesem datum sortiert aus diesen fällen
können wir auch rückschließen wie sich
zeitliche differenzen zwischen
erkrankung und meldung bei den anderen
fällen deren genaues erkrankungs datum
wir nicht kennen vermutlich verteilen
das erlaubt es uns diesen fällen dann
ein wahrscheinliches erkrankungs datum
zuzuordnen und sie ebenfalls zeitlich zu
sortieren
in einem letzten schritt berechnen wir
wie viele nachzügler üblicherweise an
den jeweiligen zurückliegenden tagen in
der vergangenheit noch nachgemeldet
wurden diese auch für die letzten tage
noch zu erwartenden fälle werden dann
imnau casting ebenfalls noch ergänzt es
ergibt sich dann die geschätzte
epidemiologische kurve nach dem
krankheit dem erkrankungsbeginn das
sogenannte now casting das heißt das
neue casting wird auf grundlage aller
vorhandenen daten durchgeführt es ist
durch die verwendung des erkrankungs
datum näher am tatsächlichen geschehen
als modelle die das melde datum zu
grunde legen und es kommt im gegensatz
zu vielen anderen modellen mit sehr
wenig annahmen aus es hat aber dennoch
durch die schätzung auch unschärfen
auf dieser grundlage wird dann die
produktionszahl berechnet im prinzip
wird für die berechnung der
reproduktions sei die zahl der
neuerkrankungen von vier tagen durch die
zahl der neuerkrankungen vier tage zuvor
geteilt die vier tage ergeben sich durch
die generation zeit das heißt der
mittleren zeit in der ein fall weitere
fälle ansteckt wichtig zu wissen diese
reproduktions zahl ist nicht
tagesaktuell sondern bildet die
infektionsrate von vor etwa eineinhalb
wochen ab hintergrund ist folgender
aufgrund zu starker schwankungen kann
keine aussage zu der anzahl der
neuerkrankungen der letzten drei tage
gemacht werden die produktionszahl von
1,07 von gestern den elften fünf 2020
basiert daher auf einem vergleich der
geschätzten anzahl von neuerkrankungen
der vier tage vom 30 04 bis zum dritten
fünften mit der mit denjenigen der vier
tage vom 45
bis zum 75 die infektionen sind noch
etwa vier bis sechs tage vor dem
jeweiligen erkrankungsbeginn entstanden
daher bezieht sich der heutige er wert
auf infektionen die etwa im zeitraum 28
vierter bis dritter fünfter
stattgefunden haben
aufgrund der oben genannten schätzung
ist auch diese re produktionszahl
grundsätzlich mit statistischen
unsicherheiten behaftet die wir durch
die produktions intervalle auch deutlich
ausweisen was können nun die ursachen
dafür seien dass die geschätzte
reproduktions zahl in den letzten tagen
leicht über 1 lag
obwohl die fallzahlen gerade in den
letzten tagen doch zu sinken schienen
erstens muss bedacht werden dass wir
erwähnt die neuerkrankungen der letzten
drei tage nicht in die berechnung
einbezogen werden können da die
schwankungen aufgrund von nachmeldungen
in der vergangenheit an diesen tagen zu
stark waren sinkende fallzahlen oder
auch scheinbar sinkende fallzahlen an
diesen tagen gehen aus methodischen
gründen daher nicht in die schätzung ein
auch für weiter auch für die weiter
zurückliegenden tage gehen wie erwähnt
weitere schätzung weitere geschätzte
fälle in die berechnung ein
die im rk ii erst noch als meldung
erwartet werden und die deshalb in den
statistiken mit den gemeldeten fällen
noch nicht dargestellt sind
wenn wir aufgrund der melde- verzögerung
in der letzten zeit noch mehr fälle
erwarten dann schlägt sich dies hier
nieder
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese fälle
dann tatsächlich auch noch gemeldet
werden ist durch das produktions
intervall dargestellt es ist also
durchaus auch nicht sicher dass alle
diese fälle noch kommen
die fallzahlen in deutschland werden
zusätzlich dass es ein dritter punkt
werden zusätzlich insgesamt langsam
kleiner dadurch beeinflussen auch
einzelne ausbrüche den wert der
reproduktions sei stärker als dies
vorher der fall war
zudem haben wir in der jüngsten
vergangenheit gleich mehrere größe aus
größere ausbrüche zb in schlachthöfen
gehabt wir können abschätzen dass diese
jüngsten ausbrüche die re
produktionszahl angehoben haben
sind diese ausbrüche unter kontrolle
kann ihre produktionszahl wieder sinken
der abfall der fallzahlen wird zunehmend
flacher und wir nähern uns einem plateau
der täglichen fallzahlen an
das bedeutet dass die produktionszahl
auch künftig um 1 herum schwanken kann
und wir müssen ihren verlauf weiter
beobachten neben dem bisher berichtete
nährwert werden wir künftig auch
zusätzlich ein geglättete nährwert
ausweisen
in diesem sind die schwankungen
ausgeglichener dargestellt er ist der
sei besser geeignet längerfristige
trends abzubilden
in der vergangenen woche lag dieser
stabile herbert an keinem tag über 1
bevor ich jetzt
auch für fragen zur verfügung stehe
möchte ich noch einmal betonen und
darauf hinweisen und die bitte äußern
an alle helfen sie mit das virus auch
weiter in schach zu halten
bleiben sie weiterhin so weit es geht zu
hause
beschränken sie weiterhin ihre kontakte
halten sie weiter abstand voneinander
mindestens 1,5 meter waschen sie sich
regelmäßig und gut die hände halten sie
sich an die husten und niesen regeln und
wenn sie im öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
unterwegs sind oder in einem geschäft
sind tragen sie bitte zusätzlich zum
abstand einem und nasen bedeckung um
andere zu schützen also eine maske aus
stoff und wenn sie sich krank bleiben
wir wenden sich krank fühlen bleiben sie
bitte unbedingt zu hause
es muss uns gelingen die fallzahlen am
besten weiter zu reduzieren und auf
niedrigen level zu halten
und wie gesagt diese reproduktionsrate
schwankend um 1 kann eben auch bedeuten
dass die fallzahlen erstmal nicht weiter
sinken sondern sich auf einem foto
einpendeln
und dann ist es umso wichtiger dass wir
diese regeln und hygieneregeln die
helfen das virus nicht weiter zu
verbreiten weiterhin anhalten einheiten
denn das virus ist und das ist glaube
ich bei einer fallzahl die etwa um
zwischen um die 900 bis 1000 liegt in
den in der letzten woche und auch heute
das virus ist immer noch in deutschland
das virus ist nicht weg vielen dank ich
freue mich auf ihre fragen vielen dank
schade wir fangen an mit der
nachrichtenagentur reuters erwartet
ja schon mittag ich habe noch eine frage
was sie zu anfang erwähnten und zwar die
test kapazitäten die ja für die
infektionszahlen neue infektionszahlen
oder ich kapazitäten sollen die zahl der
durchgeführten tests wichtig sind können
sie da mal sagen wie das in den letzten
zwei wochen wie hoch da die zahlen waren
oder wie stark die gestiegen sind zu
letzte zahl ich im kopf hatte waren so
460.000 kurz vor ende april pro woche
können sie mal sagen wie stark die
gestiegen sind also wie viele jetzt zum
beispiel in der vergangenen woche
getestet wurde und das zweite mal im
verhältnis zu den neu infektionszahlen
setzen wie die des einschätzt ja also
für alle wochen habe ich das jetzt nicht
genau im kopf die zahlen sind in etwa um
die 330.000 tests pro woche gewesen in
der 80 kalenderwoche das sind die
letzten zahlen die da zur verfügung
stehen wir werden morgen dafür wieder
die neuen zahlen für die darauffolgende
kalenderwoche dann veröffentlichen
und gleichzeitig ist der anteil der
positiven test unter diesen
durchgeführten testen auch weiter
gesunken der lag jetzt ich denke etwa
aus der erinnerung bei 4,5 prozent
und der war vorher schon mal höher also
wir hatten vorher etwas mehr teste in
einigen wochen aber auch mit einem
höheren positiven anteil dass er
natürlich auch ausdruck letztendlich das
insgesamt etwas weniger tests
durchgeführt wurden und der positiven
anteil gesunken ist ist auch ausdruck
dass natürlich insgesamt einfach weniger
fälle da sind und nachgewiesen worden
sind und in dem sinne spricht die das
sinken der positiven rate schon für ein
relativ sensitives testen und das ist ja
auch das was wir uns wünschen und hätten
sie jetzt erwartet dass aufgrund der
derzeit es jetzt die infektion seien
einige steigen müssen weil jetzt ja
wieder mehr getestet wird
also das ist natürlich so wenn man sehr
viel testet und dabei auch eben sehr
sensitiv fälle entdeckt dann kann diese
pfalz hat auch wieder steigen das können
wir nicht den fällen den einzelnen
fällen nicht nicht ansehen und es kann
durchaus sein dass die abfallenden
fallzahlen der letzten tage und wochen
in gewisser weise über ein verändertes
sensitives test verhalten etwas
überlagert sind aber die die tendenz
insgesamt wird das nach unserer
einschätzung eher nicht verändern und
vor allen dingen das ist glaube ich ein
wichtiger punkt auch in diesem
zusammenhang mit der ri produktionszahl
das test verhalten verändert die
produktionszahl nur dann wenn sie wenn
es ein sehr abrupt verändertes test
verhalten ist also wenn bei diesem
ersten vier tagen die sozusagen der
zähler sind wenn dort abrupt jetzt
vermehrt getestet wird dann kann sich
zwischendurch mal die produktionszahl
auch erhöhen aber das ganze ja einbruch
ist wird sich das dann nach wenigen
tagen wieder ausgleichen und langfristig
ist die produktionszahl dann von dem von
der häufigkeit der durchführung von
testen unabhängig kann höchstens mal
eine kleine schwankungen geben vielen
dank bevor er zu dann will man schon der
welt kommen noch die bitte dann jeweils
wenn die fragen erledigt sind wieder auf
das hand symbol klicken dass sie aus der
liste herausfallen
er will man von der welt schade sehr
schade die frage geht nochmal zur
produktionszahl man hat ja vor allem
diese zahl sehr viel bedeutung gegeben
weil es damals diese rechenmodelle gab
wenn das über eine gewisse zeit über 1
ist bei 1,1 dann wenn wir im juli schon
wieder bei einer überlastung der des
gesundheitssystems im nachhinein
betrachtet also dass ich zumindest und
ihren erklärungen mit dass man dass er
deutlich weniger dramatisch sehen dass
man einzelne tage drüber ist ist das
vielleicht auch eine fehlende
kommunikation gewesen eine falsche
kommunikation die dann so ein bisschen
diese
sie wird was sagen die story um diese
zahl dann gespürt hat jetzt nicht
unbedingt nur naiv sondern auch von
einigen experten muss man das einfach
anders einschätzen und anschließend die
frage wie lange kann die dann
tatsächlich über diesen 1,0 wer bleiben
bis es dann irgendwann doch kritisch
wird also wie lange hält man das quasi
aus ohne dass es dann eben zu diesem
exponentiellen zu wechseln kommt ja also
zur kommunikation ist es ist ein
schwieriges thema das auch jetzt meine
erläuterung waren ja auch relativ lang
und umfänglich dass man letztendlich
versteht weil wir diese
produktionszahlen zustande kommt ich
denke alle haben sich mühe gegeben
diese zahl sinnvoll zu kommunizieren
aber wie sie genau sagen die zahl wird
immer schwanken das ergibt sich aus den
aus den einfach aus den modellen egal
welches modell sie anwenden die teil
wird immer schwanken und solange sie um
den wert 1 herum schwankt ist das auch
ist es im grunde eine eine stagnation
der freizeit also die fallzahlen werden
sich dann in etwa gleicher höhe von tag
zu tag fortsetzen und bedeutet eben
keinen anstieg wenn sie dauerhaft über 1
ist dann sind wir ja schon in einem
exponentiellen wachstum das die idee die
alte exponent ist dann eben entsprechend
unterschiedlich aber dauerhaft über 1
ist dann nehmen die fallzahlen zu und
dann hat man eben auch das kriterium der
der neu ins identen fall fälle auch noch
dass man heranziehen kann aber dauerhaft
über 1 und je weiter eben über 1 desto
mehr und so schneller nehmen die fälle
dann eben zu das kann man dann
ausrechnen in der formel wie stark
dieser exponent ist und wie steil dann
die kurve ansteigen wird und damit kann
man dann natürlich daran auch prognosen
machen mit zu welchem zeitpunkt man mit
wie vielen fällen und auch mit wifi
krankenhausaufenthalten und ähnlichen
dann zu rechnen hätte aber wie gesagt
ein zwei tage mit einem geringen wert
über 1 der dann wieder runter schwanken
könnte das
das erst mal innerhalb der statistischen
ungenauigkeit wir gucken natürlich genau
hin woran kann's liegen und das sind
eben außer den ungenauigkeiten die
erwähnt hatte zu die ich erwähnt hatte
zurzeit ausbruchsgeschehen die relativ
groß sind und zum anderen eben ein
abflachen der der des abfalls der
täglichen fallzahlen so dass wir uns hin
auf einen auf ein plateau bewegen und
wenn wir an einem plateau sind dann ist
theoretisch die ihre produktionszahl 1
aber durch die statistischen
schwankungen wird sie eben dann um 1
herum schwanken
das mitnehmen kann das einzelne tage
jetzt kein großes problem sind aber weil
sie auch gesagt haben
diese zahl liegt teilweise eineinhalb
wochen zurück so ab einer woche plus
wenn sich das konstant über der 1 fällt
dann wird es theoretisch effekt haben
beziehungsweise kritisch werden
es kommt so ein bisschen wie weit über
der 1 also wenn das jetzt in der zweiten
nachkommastelle nur über der 1 ist das
wäre sicherlich auch noch nicht kritisch
aber wenn es sich weiter von der einst
entfernt 1,2 1,3 und das über eine
längere zeit das wäre sicherlich dann
schon etwas wo man eben sehr genau
hingucken muss und dann sich gedanken
machen muss man gegensteuern kann aber
einzelne tage so genau wie sie sagen
sind da nicht das problem
vielen dank wir gehen zum bayerischen
rundfunk oder frau schmidt häusler
problem der kritik von herrn professor
kroupa
zum beispiel stehen der eine fehlende
wissenschaftlichen hintergrund er
wirklich begründung der krone maßnahmen
an führt unter anderem sagte dass der
beobachtete rasante anstieg in den
neuinfektionen fast ausschließlich auf
die tatsache zurück dass die anzahl der
test mit der zeit rasant gestiegen
den namen habe ich jetzt nicht
verstanden also ich kenne jetzt seine
kritik nicht im einzelnen aber zu gerade
dieser frage da möchte ich einfach sagen
das mega eben nicht nur testergebnisse
haben sondern wir haben ja auch
patienten in krankenhäusern und diese
patienten sind krank und unter diesen
kranken patienten da haben wir eben auch
schwerstkranke patienten die dann auf
der intensivstation landen und beatmet
werden müssen mit einem krankheitsbild
das wir vorher nicht gesehen haben und
dass eben in dieser häufigkeit auch
passend zu den fällen die eben gemeldet
worden sind etwa nach 14 tagen
verschlechtert sich der zustand in der
regel dann in den krankenhäusern und
intensivstationen aufgetaucht sind also
das ist jetzt alles ein test at fakt ist
dass schließlich aus weil wir eben jahr
als ein merkmal dieser epidemie nicht
nur positive tester haben sondern
einfach auch kranke menschen darunter
sehr kranke menschen intensiv wichtige
menschen beatmungs pflichtige menschen
und todesfälle
und das ist natürlich auch ein hartes
kriterium ganz jenseits der tester
ansonsten kann ich die kritik nicht im
detail die kritik als berechtigt dass
das einfach überschätzt wurde die die
gefahr die sich nicht als berechtigt wir
gehen noch mal zum ndr wdr hackl
geworden hat schade wenn sie mich morgen
ich habe eine frage noch mal zu den
tests weil die kapazitäten doch deutlich
höher sind also kalenderwoche 18 wurden
317 1000 tests durchgeführt aber über
eine million sind die tests kapazitäten
vor diesem hintergrund wie sinnvoll
halten sie es denn die kontaktpersonen
der kategorie eins zu testen das wir
bisher ja nicht gemacht bisher werden
auch nur die kontaktpersonen kategorie
eins mit symptomen regelhaft getestet
halten sie es für sinnvoll dass
auszuweiten ob grundsätzlich testung von
kontaktpersonen
die 1 ja das kann man machen das ist
sinnvoll
es gibt ja auch symptomatische personen
insgesamt beziehungsweise sehr leicht
symptomatisch und es gibt auch personen
die vor beginn der symptome ausscheiden
das virus aus dem aus dem rachen raum
das ist sinnvoll denn bei diesen
personen die ihr ein kontakt hatten
kategorie 1 und wir haben ja auch eine
empfehlung zum ausbruch management
gemacht und da steht auch schon seit
einiger zeit ausdrücklich drin das also
dass das testen asymptomatische
kontaktpersonen je nach konstellation
und geschehen und beurteilung des
gesundheitsamtes vor ort durchaus eben
auch eine zu empfehlende maßnahme sein
kann
aber was man eben bedenken muss dass
sollte ich vielleicht noch anfügen
ein negativer test der natürlich auch
bei diesem kontaktpersonen vorkommen
kann ein negativer test schließt
natürlich eine infektion nicht aus das
heißt wenn man kontaktperson kategorie
eins ist der test ist negativ dann kann
man natürlich trotzdem später noch eine
also manifest erkranken und auch das
virus ausscheiden und das ersetzt in
diesem sinne da nicht die die quarantäne
vielen dank wir gehen zu n-tv herrn arts
montagmorgen ist schade wegkommt von der
zahl
sie sagt wenn ich richtig verstanden
habe die zahl nimmt an bedeutung ab wenn
die fallzahlen die jünger werden ja
logisch waren die ausschläge starke sind
jetzt hier die vergleiche mit der zahl
der neuinfektionen und sie sparen auch
davon dass es noch einzelne oder vor
allen dingen einzelne infektionsfälle
gibt zum beispiel in den genannten
schlacht werfen dann sieht man ja dass
die zahlen ich versuche mich formuliert
mal bewusst provokant aber nicht dass
ich mich als crooner abstempeln aber die
haben jetzt in zwölf bundesländern
fallzahlen unter 50 neue aktionen am tag
also in berlin zwei in mecklenburg
vorpommern bremen 3 sachsen-anhalt fünf
neue infektionen thüringen neu in hessen
das sind ja gefühlt 0 wenn sie jetzt in
der gesamtbetrachtung sagen dass zur
lage in deutschland also zur
gefahrenlage
wie wird es eigentlich einschätzen weil
die fallzahlen von den 933 gebieten neue
infektionen sind quasi 800 in vier
bundesländern mit der schwanken hat sie
gesagt haben wir uns ein bisschen
unsicher und darf man vor allen dingen
wirklich sehr regionalen umsichtig
mandaten infektionsherd wie ist
eigentlich das geschehen in
gesamtdeutschland zu behalten
acht momentan einzuschätzen ja also
zunächst ist es natürlich völlig richtig
dass gibt regionale unterschiede das ist
ja auch mit ein grund warum die
bekämpfungsmaßnahmen jetzt eben
regionalisiert werden und nicht mehr
überall gleich sind
oder gleich sein sollen das ist ja
letztendlich der der ausdruck eben
dieser tatsache insgesamt muss man aber
sagen die fälle die wir dort haben es
gibt eine dunkelziffer wir wissen noch
nicht genau wie die wie groß die ist es
werden ein paar mehr fälle sein das will
ich nicht dramatisieren aber hinter
jedem fall stecken immer noch ein paar
weitere fälle die zur zeit eben noch
nicht entdeckt sind das ist der der
erste punkt und der zweite punkt ist das
hilft letztendlich aber trotzdem nicht
wenn man
die regeln um infektionen zu vermeiden
eben nicht einhält einhalten würde dann
könnten eben auch diese wenigen personen
neue infektionen setzen und neue
infektionsherde neue cluster setzen und
das könnte eben wieder zu einem
aufflackern der der infektionswelle
kommen
jetzt möchte ich mal einfach ein
konkretes beispiel hier nennen also eine
person die auf einem fest mit längerer
zeit mit engen kontakt party oder
ähnlich ist die kann eben schon durchaus
mehrere infekt andere personen anstecken
und daneben einen neuen cluster setzen
und insofern denke ich ist das sehr
erfreulich dass diese infektionsraten in
einigen bereichen so zurückgegangen sind
aber ich glaube damit kann man auch
feststellen das virus ist noch da auch
wenn es deutlich weniger geworden ist es
ist nicht ihr reduziert und so lange es
nicht reduziert ist müssen wir uns so
verhalten dass wir infektionen vermeiden
damit sich keine infektionsketten
ausbilden und das bedeutet eben unser
verhalten anzupassen und den alltag so
zu gestalten dass wir solche situationen
in denen solche infektionsketten
auftreten können
daneben vermieden werden vor allen
dingen auch deshalb weil wir wissen dass
erwähnte ich schon dass es eben auch
einen anteil symptomatischer personen
gibt die das virus bereits ausscheiden
die in dem sinne nicht zu erkennen sind
ja also die gefährdung ist natürlich in
deutschland deutlich geringer als noch
vor vier wochen der fall war
die gefahrenlage aber sie ist eben nicht
weg aber das würde bedeuten konzerne
frage dass wir tatsächlich auch zu den
neuen zahlen müssen weil sonst also dass
es drei fälle mal geht jeder fünfte ein
bundesland wird wahrscheinlich der
normalzustand sein würde nächsten
monaten aus und das führt mich noch zum
anschluss frage sie sprachen wir auch
davon zweite grippewelle auf die nur 20
einstellen
gefühlt würde man sagen es hat nicht mal
die erste welle stattgefunden und zwar
nicht weil es übertrieben war das thema
sondern laden und so gut verhalten haben
ja stimmte maßnahmen durch die täter
waren sehr diszipliniert
alle bürger zusammen gäste hatten wir
haben die erste welle zum glück
verhindert 170.000 infizierten kapital
wahrscheinlich noch nicht vom richtigen
pläne sprechen wo sollte denn die zweite
und dritte welt herkommen wenn wir uns
jetzt falken also wenn wir uns alle
vernünftig verhalten und infektionen
vermeiden dann haben wir eine chance
auch die zweite welle zu vermeiden dass
das ist im grunde die botschaft aber
eben auch nur dann ja also die zweite
welle wird sich dann vermeiden lassen
wenn wir eben durch verhalten
infektionen und infektionsketten
vermeiden wenn wir das nicht tun dann
wird es wieder aufflammen an der einen
oder anderen stelle und wir wissen eben
dass es dann auch über ereignisse bei
denen mehrere menschen zu steil zu
zusammenkommen dann eben auch zu sehr
schnell zu größeren herden kommen kann
die dann wieder streuen in andere
regionen dort wieder satelliten
epidemien letztendlich verursachen und
das das kann natürlich passieren und
steuern können wir das über unser
verhalten
andersrum ausgedrückt so lange wir keine
vernünftige alternative haben zur
vermeidung von infektionen wird sich
unser alltag insofern ändern müssen als
wir eben darauf achten müssen dass wir
diese infektion durch unser verhalten
eben vermeiden ein das ist die die neue
die neue realität die wir ja auch schon
häufiger gehört haben
ein verhalten zurück so wie es
letztendlich sagen wir mal im letzten
dezember noch war das ist eigentlich
wenn man nur dann vorstellbar wenn man
eine nächste welle vermeiden will
wenn man entweder ein gutes profil aktiv
um hat also ein medikament dass man
einnehmen kann wenn die erkrankung hat
sich anbahnt sage ich mal oder eben das
wäre natürlich die ideale lösung der
impfstoff da ist so lange dass beides
nicht der fall ist und wir die nächste
welle vermeiden wollen müssen wir eben
die disziplin und auf der anderen seite
auch die fantasie aufbringen
durch unser verhalten hier die die
infektionen niedrig
wir kommen zur frau will man vom
handelsblatt gut
urteilen sie in den zusammenhang welle
die diskussion über mögliche
grenzöffnung szenario ist das eine große
gefahr mit sich bringen aus biologe ist
oder etwas im prinzip nach tiken jah jah
dass es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an
welche grenzen waren jetzt genau meint
also wenn wir jetzt sage ich mal im
europäischen kontext bleiben und die
europäischen staaten ähnliche maßnahmen
anlegen in ähnlichem stadium sind ihre
epidemie bekämpfung es ist ja in fast
allen europäischen staaten so dass die
infektionszahlen zurückgehen alle haben
ähnliche maßnahmen angewendet und auch
im moment ist gerade eine diskussion wie
denn diese wie man sich da in zukunft
gemeinsam verhalten will um eine
grenzöffnung eben zu ermöglichen
das heißt also wenn es einen gewissen
gleichklang gibt und eine ähnliche
epidemiologische situation in den
verschiedenen staaten dann denke ich
kann man so eine grenzöffnung auch und
rechtfertigen wenn man sich hier auch um
geeinigt hat denn auch innerhalb
deutschlands haben wir ja ähnliche
maßnahmen vom grundsatz wir haben aber
immer noch herde auch in deutschland die
uns aber letztendlich ja nicht
veranlassen dass wir ganz deutschland
mit sage ich mal weiteren grenzen durch
ziehen um hier die bewegungsfreiheit
einzuschränken und ähnlich kann man das
natürlich auch im größeren kontext sehen
ich denke das muss man ein bisschen
anders beurteilen wenn wenn eine
epidemie in einem land möglicherweise
unkontrolliert ist frei in der
bevölkerung zirkuliert dann ist es
sicherlich sinnvoll dass diese personen
die aus so einem land einreisen
dann auch eine häusliche quarantäne
wahrnehmen wie es im moment auch
vorgesehen ist noch
vielen dank wir gehen zur taz herr
kreutzfeldt der schöne montag schade
sie haben wir eben gesagt ist ging neben
der ritt produktionszahl sind noch
andere werte wichtig unter anderem die
zahl der täglichen neuinfektionen und da
würde mich noch mal interessieren was
sie da eigentlich für eine angemessene
zahl halten weil sie da hat sich nichts
geändert
sie haben genau zwei wochen haben sie
gesagt das müsste auch wenige hundert
pro tag sind damit die lage
kontrollierbar ist und man weitere
lockerungen von ihnen könnte und der
professor wieler hat dann vor einer
woche gesagt dass er 2010 pro tag
möglich die wir jetzt hier haben hat da
so eine starke veränderung der
einschätzung innerhalb von einer woche
gegeben oder sehen sie beide das einfach
persönlich unterschiedlich oder was ist
da der grund für diese unterschiedlichen
angaben und was halten sie aktuell für
die angemessene zahl ja also eine klare
einen klaren grenzwert ich glaube den
kann ihnen niemand hier solide benennen
auf der basis von irgendwelchen
berechnungen oder auf der basis von von
daten die man empirisch gewonnen hat das
essent letztendlich eine einschätzung
frage und ich glaube ich aber dass auch
so gesagt dass wir dass es so besser ist
je tiefer diese zahlen sind und dass uns
das dann mehr sicherheit gibt führt für
die lockerung und in dem sinne ist es
natürlich besser und das sehe ich auch
immer noch so je weniger und je geringer
die zahlen sind umso in einem um so
sicheren bereich sind wir um
letztendlich das virus durch kontakt
suche und isolierung von patienten durch
quarantäne dann auch in schach halten zu
können
und ab wann man das sich traut ist
natürlich noch eine ganz andere frage
und jetzt sind ja die ersten lockerung
wieder in gang gekommen und die
einschätzung ab wann das zu
rechtfertigen ist ist ja auch nicht so
groß unterschiedlich zwischen einigen
hundert und wenigen 100 und bis zu 1000
die die die grenze ist da
sicherlich nicht scharf und fließend und
von der größenordnung ist das sage ich
mal sicherlich nicht so weit auseinander
als dass das einen monat als echter
widerspruch interpretiert werden kann
dazu noch mal nachgefragt die grenze von
50 pro 100000 in einem land in einem
landkreis und pro woche ist ja auch
kritisiert wurden von einigen experten
zu hoch gerade auch für große landkreise
können sie nochmal sagen ob sie diese
50er grenze pro woche pro 100000
einwohner für angemessen halten oder zu
hoch ich hatte ja schon mal gesagt ich
halte das für eine für eine pragmatische
grenze und ich möchte auch an dieser
stelle nochmal wiederholen dass ich
glaube es ist ein großes missverständnis
zu sagen das sei eine grenze von 50
personen pro 100000 einwohner pro woche
in einem landkreis dass er eine grenze
ab der mann dann aktiv werden soll
also das ist mitnichten so man soll
jeden einzelnen fall identifizieren
isolieren und die kontakte suchen
man soll sich um jeden einzelnen
ausbruchs herd um jeden cluster in jeder
in jeder gemeinschaftseinrichtung in
jeder fabrik muss man sich kümmern um
jeden einzelnen das ist der job des der
gesundheitsämter das machen die sowieso
und je besser sie das machen um so umso
niedriger sind die fallzahlen und umso
besser ist das auch für uns alle
diese grenze von den 50 pro 100.000 das
ist nach meinem verständnis eine eine
grenze ab der dann übergeordnete stellen
des landes letztendlich eingebunden
werden um über die erforderlichkeit von
eskalation maßnahme also von von
maßnahmen die letztendlich die die
bekämpfung eskalieren nachzudenken und
das wären zum beispiel natürlich
quarantäne das wären wieder weitere
ausgangs beschränkungen über die muss
man ab dieser grenze zusätzlich zu dem
ganz normalen geschäft der kontaktsuche
der bekämpfung von ausbrüchen zusätzlich
zu diesen ganz normalen geschäft
nachdenken
und da kann man auch jetzt keine
grundsätzliche lösungen vorschlagen
sondern es gibt hier unterschiedliche
konstellationen die zu dieser
überschreiten des grenzwertes führen
können wir haben zum beispiel ausbrüche
in schlachthöfen die wie es einerseits
machen können oder auch in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften
das sind relativ begrenzte lokalisierte
geschehen die man auch mit dann
entsprechend begrenzten lokalisierten
maßnahmen in den griff bekommen kann und
ist eine andere konstellation denkbar
dass man eben diese infektionsketten
nicht so klar lokalisieren kann das ist
ein freies zirkulieren des virus in der
bevölkerung gibt da muss man dann eben
über andere maßnahmen nachdenken unter
anderem zum beispiel auch über über eine
weitere reduktion von kontakten also ich
verstehe das so dass diese 50 pro
100.000 eben die schwelle sind wo man
sich genau diese fragen stellen muss
das ist keinesfalls die schwelle ab der
mann erst aktiv werden soll
das muss man bei jedem einzelnen fall
wir gehen zum focus herr meier
vielen dank ich hätte eine kurze frage
zu einem anderen thema es häufen sich
die beobachtungen in anderen ländern
kinder usa frankreich italien dass
raucher signifikant seltener 1900
franken als nichtraucher hat das lka
dazu jetzt nur aus epidemiologischer
sicht sozusagen eigene erkenntnisse und
wenn ja es schießens ziehen sie daraus
für schüsse nein dazu kann ich im moment
nicht sagen wird dass erhoben
also wir untersuchen risikofaktoren ja
und da ist da ist das natürlich auch
eine frage aber ich kann da ihnen keine
zahlen zur zeit nennen und ob wir das in
irgendeiner form bestätigen können
[Musik]
frau schweiz mediengruppe rtl ja ich hab
mal ne frage sie haben vorhin gesagt das
ende der produktion um die 1 ist dann
nähert man sich ein plateau das ist das
was sie derzeit bei den zahlen der
neuinfektionen beobachten ist das
typisch für so eine pandemie und ist es
schwierig von diesem plateau oder noch
tiefer zu kommen ich bin in der
bestimmte
eine rolle ja also typisch für eine
pandemie ist das ist das nicht das ist
denke ich auch ein ausdruck des
gleichgewichts das ist ein ausbruch des
gleichgewichts zwischen zwischen
infektiosität des virus und und
infektions verhalten der infektions
vermeiden dem verhalten tschuldigung der
bevölkerung in deutschland wenn das
entsprechend sich auf einem
gleichgewicht einpendelt dann hat man
eben diesen diesen umstand dass eine
person im schnitt eine weitere person an
steckt nichts anderes war heißt dass
jahre produktionszahl um 1 und deshalb
betone ich ja auch immer so wieder dass
letztendlich die der weitere verlauf von
unserem verhalten abhängt denn dieses
gleichgewicht das können wir nur
beeinflussen durch unser eigenes
verhalten an dieser stelle grundsätzlich
wenn wir jetzt das nicht tun würden dass
der der normale natürliche verlauf wäre
eben das eine eine welle vorübergeht
bisschen an bestimmten regionen und
bestimmten altersgruppen eine sag mal
teilimmunität erreicht ist dann sinken
die infektionszahlen bis dann
letztendlich wieder durch
dadurch dass immunität lehrt nachlässt
auf der einen seite dass sich die
bevölkerung anders durchmischt das
vielleicht auch junge personen wieder
dazu kommen bis dann eine nächste welle
wieder in gang gehen würde so lange bis
die immunität in der bevölkerung relativ
gleichmäßig verteilt ist also so lange
würden wellen durch die durch die
bevölkerung laufen
der zeitliche abstand kann jetzt hier
bei dem koma virus sich ja auch noch
nicht genau vorhergesagt werden weil man
dass wir es noch nicht so lange kennt
und es würde erst dann zum stillstand
kommen wenn man eben diese so genannte
herdenimmunität hätte ja insofern ist
das jetzt kein typischer natürlicher
verlauf wenn sich so ein plateau
einstellt und auch längere zeit erhält
sondern das ist das das ergebnis
von verhaltensänderung ok also um das zu
senken möchten wir noch besser werden ja
genau
ganz klar vielen dank herr kind zu
planet interview herr buhre vielen dank
ich habe noch eine frage zur gesundheits
folgenabschätzung also oder auch zu den
kollateralschäden der korona maßnahmen
her wieder sagte er hier vor zwei wochen
habe ich ende april
wir sind und all dieser
kollateralschäden bewusst wir können sie
noch nicht quantifizieren werden das
aber tun im nachhinein meine frage ist
ab wann wird man sich denn auch mit den
kollateralschäden befassen also
medizinisch wie auch soziale ab wann
wird man das im blick nehmen und zwei
frage wo sehen sie denn überhaupt die
zuständigkeit für diese frage befasst
sich das rk ii damit oder ist ihre
zuständigkeit jetzt allein bei der
eindämmung der pandemie
danke ja wir haben ja im
robert-koch-institut auch eine aufgabe
zum monitoring von nicht übertragbaren
krankheiten das macht bei uns die
abteilung 2 sonntags berichterstattung
und und gesundheitsmonitoring und da
erfassen wir ja die gesundheit der
bevölkerung in regelmäßigen wellen und
werden auch sekundär daten aus anderen
quellen daraus also nicht daten die wir
selbst erheben
um letztendlich zu diesen ergebnissen zu
kommen und das werden wir auch machen
da haben wir zum teil auch schon
begonnen sich von uns diese daten
anzuschauen
also insofern ist das ein teil unserer
aufgabe aber es ist natürlich nicht
ausschließlich unsere aufgabe es gibt ja
auch andere wissenschaftler die sich mit
nicht übertragbaren krankheiten und der
über die biologie beschäftigen große
epidemiologische institut und die werden
sich das sicherlich auch angucken
also es ist teil unserer aufgaben moment
sicherlich nicht so intensiv verfolgt
wie das zu normalen zeiten der fall wäre
weil auch die kollegen aus der abteilung
2 jetzt hier im upton geschehen stark
unterstützen die werden zum beispiel
diese epidemiologischen studien
durchführen die ja noch diesen monat
beginnen
aber das steht mit auf unserer auf
unserer liste der dinge die zu erledigen
sind und die auch teilweise schon
begonnen werden
aber wie gesagt andere können auch auf
diesem gebiet forschen und tun das auch
und beginnen auch damit können wir die
die kritik nachvollziehen
auch an der regierung die zum teil gibt
dass man eben solche der
folgenabschätzung im moment noch nicht
betreibt dass man die kollateralschäden
der kroner maßnahme überhaupt nicht in
den blick nimmt das ist ja das glaube
ich auch was viele viele bürger bewegt
man einerseits hat man das virus ein
aber sein ob man nicht was man mit den
maßnahmen anrichtet können sie die
kritik nachvollziehen
also ich kann die die sorge kann ich
nachvollziehen ich glaube aber nicht
dass das dass das so pauschal stimmt ich
glaube dass die regierung sehr wohl auch
diese dinge im blick hat und das zeigt
sich ja an verschiedenen dingen das
zeigt sich unter anderem daran dass die
maßnahmen in deutschland verglichen mit
vielen anderen staaten auch als sie
eingeführt worden sind nicht so streng
waren also wir konnten alle raus gehen
wir konnten alle spazieren gehen konnten
alle sport treiben im freien und so
weiter das war uns ein erlaubte konnten
alle auch im begrenzten umfang kontakte
haben
das war ja weiterhin möglich vieles ist
jetzt erst in der letzten woche in
spanien überhaupt möglich geworden was
bei uns von anfang an möglich war also
es waren ja nicht die strengsten
maßnahmen die man sich vorstellen kann
sondern es waren maßnahmen aus meiner
sicht mit augenmaß die zur reduktion der
fallzahlen geführt haben aber trotzdem
natürlich noch eine eine gewisse
bewegungsfreiheit gelassen haben und
auch diese maßnahmen sind ja jetzt nach
und nach und zwar so schnell ist recht
zu rechtfertigen schien unter dem aspekt
infektionsschutz nach und nach gelockert
worden also man hat ja diese maßnahmen
jetzt auch nicht angehalten und
angezogen
bis man hier auf einen 1 0 wert gekommen
ist sondern man hat ja denke ich auch
mit bedacht
die lockerung bereits vollzogen als es
noch dass hier immer noch der fall immer
noch auch infektionsfälle gibt und das
heißt ich schon auch für ein ausdruck
dessen dass man sich dieser
nebenwirkungen seien sie jetzt
gesundheitlicher art gesellschaftlicher
art oder auch wirtschaftlicher art
durchaus sehr bewusst ist beginn zuvor
satori von wie der hallo guten tag
können sie mich hören ja ich wollte noch
mal auf die ausbrüche zurück das ist ja
nicht nur die ausbrüche jetzt in
schlachthöfen sondern das war bis vor
kurzem zumindest auch in mehreren
pflegeheim auch dass man daraus brüche
festgestellt hat und es wurde schon vor
längerem gesagt dass überlegt wird oder
konzepte entwickelt werden dass man oder
wie man dann in pflegeheimen auch
regelmäßig symptomlose zum beispiel
teuer testet also zweimal die woche zum
beispiel wie weit ist man bei diesen
überlegungen gibt es ein bundesweites
konzept oder gibt es eine empfehlung des
robert koch instituts also wann wird man
endlich in den pflegeheimen mehr testen
es gibt eine eine empfehlung des robert
koch instituts zur prävention von
ausbrüchen in pflegeeinrichtungen und
auch zu maßnahmen wenn diese ausbrüche
stattfinden
da ist natürlich auch das testen ein ein
punkt der wird dort auch angesprochen
und abgehandelt und vom grundsatz her
ist es auch zu empfehlen in solchen
ausbruch situationen personal und auch
bewohner zu zu testen wie das jetzt
genau vor sich geht nach welchem schema
ob man die proben pult oder nicht pult
in welchen zeitlichen abständen da muss
auch eine gewisse flexibilität sein um
das letztendlich vor ort entsprechend zu
organisieren und umsetzen zu können
also vom grundsatz her ist es empfohlen
wie es genau gemacht wird muss dann
unter den gegebenheiten vor ort
entsprechend geschaut werden
eine nachfrage nach und ist die
überlegung ob man sowas ausweitet auf
kitas und schulen im moment nicht würden
sie so was empfehlen
wenn ein ausbruch da ist schon ja also
durchaus sprüche sind dort wo ausbrüche
sind da sollte man grundsätzlich und vor
allen dingen wenn es
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen sind ganz
grundsätzlich testen was anderes ist es
praktisch eine routine testung zu machen
wenn da eben kein hinweis auf ein
ausbruch ist und in die richtung gehen
zurzeit die überlegungen für schulen und
kindergärten nicht wenn ein ausbruch da
ist selbstverständlich wir gehen zum
medico direkt ja hätte mich ja wir haben
sie ja thomas jährigen mit
erlauben sie mir den betrachtungen
einmal auch zu ziehen sie hatten eben
erwähnt das ist auch für die nicht
übertragbare erkrankung aufgabenbereich
des ake gibt und es fällt auf dass die
derzeitigen kooperation zwischen
wissenschaft und politik und lkw zu
bewundernswerten im internationalen
vergleich lobenswerten erfolgen führt
dass jedes institut für health metrics
and evaluation schätzt die gesamtzahl in
deutschland wahrscheinlich irgendwo beim
ceiling effekt von 10.000 was eigentlich
ein fantastisches ergebnis
meine frage geht in eine ganz andere
richtung wir haben seit vielen vielen
jahren mit jahrzehnten eine epidemie in
deutschland die wesentlich mehr tote
erforderte oder einfordert die tabak
epidemie und es stellt sich mir die
frage wie kann es bewerkstelligt werden
dass eine ähnlich gute kooperation
zwischen wissenschaft politik und rwe
zustande kommt um die täglich etwa 330
340 toten jährlich etwa 120.000 toten
durch die tabak in gleicher weise in den
griff zu bekommen
er müsste da wen beauftragen und welche
rolle hätte das akg ja also ich denke
die frage ist natürlich völlig
berechtigt ist vielleicht nicht so im
fokus der des heutigen briefings wir
trotzdem gerne kurz darauf eingehen
also wir haben ja hier jetzt
einfach nochmal auf den unterschied auch
hinweisen wir haben hier eine akute
situation die auch akut sich stark
verschlechtern könnte wenn entsprechend
nicht umsichtig gehandelt wird und die
entsprechenden infektionsschutz
maßnahmen getroffen werden
und da ist es natürlich auch klar dass
das man zeitlich gedrängt daneben sehr
sage ich mal sehr intensiv sich abstimmt
und entsprechende maßnahmen ergreift
aber auch hier bei der bei der kur wird
19 epidemie ist es ja nicht so dass das
rp jetzt hier allein auf weiter flur
steht auch was letztendlich die die
health promotion also die die
gesundheitsinformationen und die
gesundheitliche aufklärung angeht
sondern srg ist hier ein teil der
fachliche empfehlungen gibt und berät
aber die die kampagnen die aufklärung
der bevölkerung mit spezifischen
zielgruppen spezifischen materialien
informationen und kampagnen das ist ja
eigentlich nicht unsere aufgabe das
passiert natürlich hier jetzt auch in
diesem briefing aber da gibt es ja die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung die hier auch jetzt bei coop
19 entsprechende materialien zur
verfügung stellt und aufklärung in der
bevölkerung auch mit dem ziel
selbstverständlich der der information
über das richtige verhalten um
infektionen zu vermeiden zur verfügung
stellt und genau so ist es natürlich
auch beim rauchen auch da hat die bz gaa
die hauptaufgabe die bevölkerung zu
informieren macht entsprechende
kampagnen die gibt es ja es gibt diese
raucher kampagnen an verschiedenen
stellen und wir erheben eben durch
unsere studien durch die querschnitt
studien vor allen dingen zur erfassung
des gesundheitszustandes in der
bevölkerung hier jetzt mal dext zu
nennen als eine dieser studien oder auch
künftige geplante studien da erfassen
wir ja die gesundheit und auch die
risikofaktoren da gehört rauch und
selbstverständlich auch dazu und liefern
da darüber daten nicht wir allein aber
wir liefern eben dann repräsentative
daten über das verhalten von rauchern in
deutschland und über
die gesundheitlichen folgen und diese
daten werden dann eben auch genutzt von
der politik und der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung um dann
präventionsprogramme in diesem bereich
zu machen also das gibt es vielleicht im
moment nicht so sichtbar und insofern
denke ich dass das die frage moment eine
frage der sichtbarkeit ist und die frage
des erfolgs warum hat man hier jetzt
vielleicht in dem letzten halben jahr
großen erfolg gehabt beim rauchen über
die letzten jahrzehnte vielleicht nicht
so sichtbaren das kann man auch denke
ich einen orden rauchen zieht sich ja
aus vielen bereichen der gesellschaft
immer weiter zurück also es gibt auch da
diese erfolge das sind aber sehr
etablierte verhaltensweisen in der
bevölkerung und die sind eben schwer zu
beeinflussen dass man da weiter
dranbleiben muss aber ich würde auch
sagen dass die die anti raucher
kampagnen und ähnliches in deutschland
schon auch durchaus erfolgreich sind
vielen dank
wir gehen zur frau schmidt vom münchen
ja wir hören sie sie haben in einer
pressekonferenz mitte april bestätigt
dass das immunsystem der kinder
aufgebaut und trainiert werden muss um
eine residenz für das gesamte leben zu
sichern
jetzt sind wieder einige wochen ins land
gegangen ist es denn überhaupt noch
verantwortbar die kinder weiter zu
isolieren und über normale
hygienemaßnahmen zu verlangen
sie waren jetzt unter dem aspekt des
aufbaus des immunsystems genau wenn
diese maßnahmen das isolieren betrifft
ja auch alle anderen viren und alle
anderen bakterien ja das halte ich für
verantwortbar ok nachfrage sie sprachen
vorhin wie er davon das virus infizieren
zu wollen also ausrotten meinen sie das
tatsächlich wenn wir jetzt wissen dass
wir das virus ja auch bei hier
nachweisen können
ein wichtiger aus meiner sicht wäre doch
zu erfahren wann wird es denn endlich
valide zahlen aus dem rk ii zu ihnen
steht in der bevölkerung geben
also dann haben sie mich missverstanden
ich habe eigentlich gesagt dass das ist
natürlich wünschenswert wäre wenn wir
das virus ausrotten könnten und dass die
voraussetzung wäre um letztendlich
überhaupt gar nicht mehr im alltag daran
zu denken
entsprechende vorsichtsmaßnahmen
hygienemaßnahmen verhaltensmaßnahmen zu
anzuwenden ich habe nicht gesagt dass
ich das für ein realistisches ziel habe
halte ich habe mehrfach hier auch in
dieser runde betont dass das
wünschenswert wäre dass ich das aber aus
verschiedenen gründen für nicht
realistisch heute ein grund ist eben
auch die weltweite verbreitung des virus
so dass ja das überhaupt nur sinn machen
würde wenn man es in einer weltweit
koordinierten aktionen angehen würde
weil sonst würde das virus hier immer
von allen möglichen ecken und aus allen
möglichen himmelsrichtungen wieder nach
deutschland zurückkommen können also
eradikation kann man natürlich nur
global denken also insofern habe ich das
jetzt nicht als ziel hier formuliert
dann bin ich missverstanden worden
zur zweiten frage ich hatte gesagt dass
wir mit den geologischen studien im mai
anfangen
und ich weiß nicht ob ich ihre fragen
dann richtig verstanden habe dann wissen
wir natürlich auch wie viele personen in
diesen stichproben die wir dann ziehen
bereits kontakt mit dem virus hatten
zero konvertiert sind also antikörper im
blut haben und dann mit einiger
wahrscheinlichkeit auch eine immunität
gegen dieses virus aufweisen welche
antikörper jetzt genau die immunität
verursacht das wissen wir nicht so ganz
genau
das heißt eine ein antikörpertest und
das noch mal zu sagen ein antikörpertest
so wie sie im moment vorhanden sind der
kann immunität für einen längeren
zeitraum zur zeit nicht bestätigen
der kann aber auskunft darüber geben ob
ein kontakt stattgefunden hat mit dem
virus eine auseinandersetzung des
immunsystems und dann können wir
eigentlich für die nächsten monate bis
wenige jahre so ist es in der regel bei
coronaviren von einer immunität ausgehen
aber die daten dazu haben wir noch nicht
und diese zero studien beginnen im mai
und dann wissen wir wer schon in diesen
stichproben mit dem virus
gezielt war wir gehen zur letzten frage
epoque times voraussichtlich morgen sie
hatten freunde das gesundheitsmonitoring
angesprochen und ende der vergangenen
woche ist ja eine analyse des inzwischen
beurlaubten mitarbeiters des
bundesinnenministeriums an die
öffentlichkeit gelangt danach heißt es
in deutschland offenbar dass in
deutschland offenbar mehr menschen durch
die folgen der korona maßnahmen und
gesundheits und pflegesystem gestorben
sein als das durch als durch das virus
selbst jetzt an die mediziner und
wissenschaftler die an dieser analyse
beteiligt waren nochmal eine aktuelle
stellungnahme geschrieben und daran
steht wir in wissenschaft und praxis
sowie sehr viele kolleginnen und
kollegen erleben täglich die
folgeschäden der korona schutzmaßnahmen
unserer praxis in unseren patienten
ziel der maßnahme müsste es sein die
risikogruppen zu schützen ohne die
medizinische versorgung und die
gesundheit der gesamtbevölkerung zu
gefährden so wie es gerade leider
geschieht wie bewerten sie diese
aussagen und liegen dem rk ii zahlen vor
die dagegen oder dafür sprechen oder
wann es mit diesen zahlen auch zu
rechnen
ich denke die frage habe ich beantwortet
also im moment haben wir dann noch keine
zahlen die uns aufschluss darüber geben
welche welche gesundheitlichen
nebenwirkungen nicht infektiösen bereich
und in welcher qualität hier auftreten
das denke ich was zur zeit vorliegt das
sind eben diese beobachtungen dass in
bestimmten arztpraxen notaufnahmen und
ähnlichem eben entsprechend weniger
patienten sich vorstellen das ist eine
beobachtung die zahlen dazu was das
jetzt wirklich bedeutet für die
gesundheit da da kenne ich noch keine
belastbaren zahlen
vielen dank dann sind wir am ende und
bis zur nächsten anlassbezogenen
pressebriefing werden sie gesund
auf wiedersehen
[Applaus]